no okay but I'm saying to you that I  don't wake up like this okay I came here  even just be myself not here as in here  here to the UK in general even the way I  speak because I speak with an Italian  mentality to say it's rude it's too  strong it's too forward  a lot of people don't cannot work with  that you understand I'm not saying that  I'm intimidating I'm saying I'm being  told I'm intimidating I don't think I am  not the numbers  if you understand enough that it's like  part of your Italian habits it habits  from another language then surely you  can just like you know solve for value  and be like all right I'll adjust  there's a lot of Italians there who  manage to not be seen as rude it's very  difficult it's not it's not you see it  nice adjusting yourself so I have to be  myself have self-love instead the same  time I just myself like this is why this  Society is going to Baba